[ __ ]
this is the Moody
God of War Ragnarok is a lavish
production with pristine visuals
jaw-dropping scale crunchy combat that
is as satisfying as it is brutal and a
world that begs to have its every corner
and crevice explored it's a spectacular
Blockbuster but these are the least of
its achievements in a game where a
hulking God rips all manner of creatures
limb from limb the most shocking moments
aren't bathed in blood but carried by
poignant words and heartfelt emotions
[Music]
they are a former god of war known for
mercilessly killing his kin finding the
words to empathize with loss A
despondent child imploring a father to
break a self-destructive cycle a moment
of tenderness in the life of a boy that
has the weight of the world on his
shoulders God of War ragnarok's most
impressive achievements are its
exploration of loss and love grief and
growth determinism and Defiance it's an
astoundingly well-written game that
deconstructs the mythology of Norse gods
and rebuilds it as an odyssey about
families its story isn't about the end
of the world but those that have a hand
in it they're revered as mythical Gods
but are characterized by Deep flaws
Twisted by skewed perspectives and
corrupted by questionable motivations in
the same way the people they preside
over are and yet some also have
Redemptive qualities in that respect
ragnarok's story is told from a gray
area where nuances blur the line between
heroes and villains Good and Evil by
constantly challenging you to reconsider
who they are and the factors that drive
their actions these characters remain
compelling throughout there are moments
when characters you're not supposed to
be rooting for reveal the trials and
tribulations that have shaped them or
the demons they battle this alone is
enough to humanize them but Ragnarok
also mirrors the struggles of the
protagonists in the antagonists forcing
you to ask yourself if I'm willing to
empathize with the good guys because of
what they're going through shouldn't I
also do the same for the bad guys the
answer it turns out is very complicated
and that's what makes this story so
captivating although Kratos and atreus
are the stars of the show almost every
character is in the midst of their own
complicated Journey for some it's one
that will lift them from a pit of
despair or pull them from darkness and
onto a brighter path for others it's one
that fuels obsessions that could be the
undoing of everything and everyone this
is best illustrated by Kratos and atreus
who by killing balder at the end of the
last game act as the harbingers of the
end times the consequences of this
moment wait differently on them and what
they feel is their responsibility
because of their actions pull them in
different directions Kratos who has
finally learned to guide his son through
love instead of fear focuses on Staring
him away from the conflict and the
Affairs of the Acer Gods but does so
with the knowledge that his son is
prophesied to play a part in Ragnarok
and he is destined to die atreus
meanwhile is compelled to prevent
Ragnarok and find out who he is as Loki
the name he was given by the Giants and
sets off to find tear the Norse god of
war to achieve his goals this
complicated Dynamic serves as the
conflict between them a man that wants
to avoid war at all costs Having learned
the Toler extracts firsthand versus a
boy who believes war is the only way to
unsee a power that has ruined the lives
of so many in in action is also a risk
you taught me that
stop thinking like a father for a moment
and start thinking like a general no
those who remember atreus's power
tripping fledgling God phase from the
last game will also remember how
frustrating it was to go through that
there's nothing more annoying than an
arrogant child but Ragnarok treats the
differences in perspective between
Father and Son in a much different way
Kratos is now Reckoning with letting his
son Forge his own path and learning that
holding on too tight could push him away
atreus has matured since we last saw him
and he is now more cognizant that his
actions can and will have consequences
as a result the dynamic has shifted to
where Kratos is trying to learn about
his son instead of Define him while
atreus does his best to see things from
his father's perspectives and in both
cases mimia's Council plays a major part
in this the fruits of the journey that
both characters underwent in the
previous game are carried forward into
the sequel and thanks to the superb
writing and acting the back and forth
between them are genuinely interesting
there's a newfound sense of mutual
respect in these conversations which is
Uncharted Territory for Kratos an intern
feeds into the motif of growth that
underpins God of War Ragnarok this is a
game where you will see people change in
meaningful ways without revealing
details new characters and those you
became intimately familiar with in the
previous game have experiences that
profoundly impact them and the people
around them God of War Ragnarok is rich
in themes to unpack from the influence
of families and generational trauma to
how abuses of power and emotional
manipulation can change people God of
War Ragnarok places the Norse pantheon
under the harshest of Lights to show how
deeply flawed they are and we're able to
explore that thoroughly through our own
experiences with them as well as Tales
told by others that have their own mimir
the self-professed smartest man alive
returns to offer his Insight on all
things Norse history as do the various
writings scattered throughout the Realms
that recount the complex histories the
tales of notable figures all provide
insight into the thoughts and feelings
of various characters God of War
Ragnarok is a long game but at every
step of the journey the writing and
characterization make it count it
justifies that runtime by cultivating an
intimacy with the characters that is
only possible by spending hours and
hours with them learning how they see
the world and what influences their
thinking and pretty much every character
is fascinating but especially the Acer
Gods who can be cruel at the best of
times with the looming threat of their
demise however each of them begins to
unravel in different ways for some their
nature becomes concentrated further
which has unfortunate repercussions
others however are forced to rethink
what truly matters to them there have
been a lot of takes on Norse mythology
but God of War ragnarok's is easily one
of the most memorable it's elevated by
the presence of Kratos whose past life
as a Greek god provides him with a
unique perspective but also because he's
placed at the center of it the legends
that we're used to are molded around him
and his son and they adhere in a way
that is truly impressive when all is
said and done you can stand back and
Marvel at how neatly and creatively
different strands of narratives and
characterization from older God of War
titles the previous entry in this
rebooted series and Norse mythology as a
whole have been weaved together
Kratos and atreus's enemies on the
battlefield God of War Ragnarok doesn't
make any drastic departures from the
previous game though there are some new
additions and expansions made to key
mechanics fundamentally however the core
gameplay Remains the Same and this is in
its favor my familiarity with the
previous game meant it was very easy to
begin tearing my way through the
battlefield and the close camera angle
offers a dramatic front row seat to the
brutality kratos's legendary reputation
is built upon there's a maniacal kind of
Glee that comes from stomping around
Arena swinging the trusty Leviathan ax
to cleave Drago's elves Dragons demons
and all manner of other Fantastical
creatures
look
even all these hours later the thrill of
hurling the ax into the distance and
then recalling it back to your side
hasn't diminished one bit and with new
skill trees to work through this ability
continues to provide ample opportunities
to create flashy combos that hit hard
this time around Kratos also has access
to the blades of chaos from the outset
and Sony Santa Monica has put them to
Great use as well as serving as
excellent crowd control tools and
dishing out extra damage to ice align
creatures the fiery blades are also used
to emphasize mobility and verticality
Kratos can latch onto enemies and close
their distance with the blades which
means they are very handy for Target
prioritization and even Escape tactics
but they're also essential for quickly
ascending to elevated platforms where
enemies often position themselves to
take part shots this means you'll need
to have a much Keener awareness of your
surroundings and ensure these threats
are dressed quickly a small but very
welcome new edition is the ability to
launch off elevated areas and execute
plunging attacks on those below which
ensures that the sense of momentum that
is built-in skirmishes isn't lost when
moving around the battlefield my
favorite weapon remains kratos's trusty
fists which hit like Boulders and
generate a significant amount of stun
like the previous game enemies have a
stun meter which when filled opens them
up in devastating cinematic finishes
that are weapon specific and usually
involve rendering something into
crushing bones or eviscerating the enemy
entirely
it's a wince inducing kind of
viciousness that really drives home the
power fantasy of being a god which is
ironic considering that Kratos and God
of War Ragnarok is a much more balanced
and I dare say emotionally stable person
that contrast actually ends up working
for the game as it becomes a stark
reminder of how far Kratos has come to
be able to cage that kind of Beast
Within him another area that has been
expanded is Shields you were previously
limited to just one but in Ragnarok
Kratos has access to a wider range of
shields each one usually has a playstyle
it caters to so for those who want to
focus on parrying attacks to create
openings there are a selection that will
enable that but if you're the kind of
person that likes the tank damage bigger
and sturdier options are also available
Shields also usually have a secondary
function that is executed by tapping L1
twice to check an enemy and create space
slam the shield into the ground and
break guard retaliate with a punch that
knocks them back or even Rush forward
this new wrinkle further enhances the
offensive feel of combat by letting you
go from the back foot to the front in an
instant it it's a smart little addition
that means you can switch up your
playstyle should you want to
enhancing what Kratos is capable of are
the various role-playing systems that
are tied to the equipment naturally
equipment can be upgraded to improve
their strength the effectiveness of the
element they are imbued with or the
power of their unique runic attack among
other things but the most tangible
additions are often in the attachments
some of which will further enhance
attributes While others go so far as to
introduce new functionality like sending
consecutive waves of Frost with every
swing of the ax armor is treated
similarly by starring pluses and minuses
to attributes or having a unique effect
that is activated by certain conditions
none of this is particularly game
changing or Innovative but it does offer
the freedom to create a build for Kratos
that caters to your style of play
kratos's aggression is reflected in his
enemies which hit much harder than
before and aim to overwhelm in the early
hours this is fine but as the game ramps
up and trickier enemies appear the
mechanics can struggle under the
pressure of the increased speed and
aggression these enemies often absorb
much more damage have multiple phases or
move around and and can attack from a
distance and in many cases there can be
multiple of them because of this it can
often feel like you're being pulled in
multiple directions and cracks in the
defensive options form I often found
myself in the middle of a series attack
and then suddenly an enemy would appear
from behind forcing me to disengage
either by turning around or rolling out
of the way the quick turn input is now
L1 and down on the directional pad and
even as I approach the end of the game
it felt awkward and unreliable to
execute especially in the heat of battle
you can remap it but I never found a
place where I was completely comfortable
with it this also felt like it was
breaking the flow of combat especially
since the intensity made it easy to lose
track of the on-screen arrow that
indicates an attack coming from behind
the indicator switches from yellow to
Red to provide some idea of timing but I
still found myself getting clipped a lot
although this isn't a big deal for much
of the game in the latter half enemies
can stun lock you so there were numerous
occasions where a single enemy would
open me up to being pummeled by multiple
and I'd die in an instant these moments
arose in a way where I felt ill-equipped
and incapable of making Kratos react in
a way that could deal with what was
being thrown at me as opposed to not
being able to execute because of my own
skill since there are high level
challenges equivalent to the Valkyries
from the previous game and more than a
few that are even trickier this is the
kind of thing that can be the difference
between life and death thankfully for
boss fights at least God of War Ragnarok
is much better about checkpointing you
as you move through phases and when
you're getting stuck into combat a trace
is much more capable this time around
along with mimir he will either do call
outs to keep you informed or fire off
some arrows at your command or of his
own volition to get threats off you he's
a good lad are you watch out
ultimately although these issues can be
irksome they are small and in the grand
scheme of things don't drastically
impact how the mechanics coalesce combat
is much pacier and more Dynamic than
before and it is thrilling regardless of
whether you're fighting a smattering of
draggers or trading blows with Gods it's
thoughtfully designed and thoroughly
satisfying from the first swing of the X
to the very last
Kratos and atreus's battles take them
across all nine Realms which is a change
from the previous game where two of the
Realms were locked away one of the most
interesting parts of God of War Ragnarok
is how it reimagines areas that were in
the original game thimblewinter is used
as a narrative conceit to give these
familiar locales New Life in Norse
mythology thimble winter which
translates to The Long Winter serves as
the Prelude to Ragnarok in game it
affects the nine Realms in different
ways midgard for example is besieged by
a bitter cold so when you return to the
Lake of the nine once again it has
completely frozen over key areas of the
lake that you may have become familiar
with in the last game May now be
inaccessible as new parts of it open up
a cold wind sweeps across the icy
surface of the lake and at the center of
it all tears Temple is now barely
recognizable under the buildup of snow
in the distance icy mountain peaks serve
as the backdrop to a single lightning
strike Frozen in place as the mark of an
intense battle naturally navigation is
completely changed since you can no
longer sail the waters instead Kratos
and atreus get around on a sled that is
pulled by their trusty pet walls which
is a nice way to mix up the way you get
around at certain points you can even
use their Keen sense of awareness to
sniff out objectives which is a nice
touch spartal fine by comparison looks
picturesque from the outskirts with its
bright blue skies but as you venture
deeper into its Wetlands it becomes more
desert-like with craggy rocks awkwardly
jutting out and collapse wooden mining
equipment filling the spaces in between
there's an unpleasant arid atmosphere to
it and yet at the same time it's quite
the visual spectacle to behold rich in
detail and intricate in its construction
vanheim home of the Vanier is a verdant
Forest that has reclaimed much of the
landscape trees gently Sway in the wind
Moss has settled Atop The Water and
vegetation snakes along Stone floors and
up onto man-made shrines and if you take
a moment to stop and look around you'll
find Wildlife nestled amongst all the
green it's a place that is very alive
which makes it a nice contrast to the
coldness of midgar or the glistening
Majesty of alfheim's architecture there
are other areas I won't spoil some of
which have a good amount to see and do
While others serve a specific function
no one area in God of War Ragnarok comes
across as big as the lake of nine but it
seems like this is a symptom of how
you're constantly moving around a
variety of locations as opposed to
repeatedly returning to one regardless
each realm has a grand sense of scale
and as you move between them the scope
of the world as a whole far eclipses
what came before while the main story
campaign moves Kratos and the trails
through all nine Realms there are plenty
of side quests to undertake in each of
these locations yet another Testament to
the writing is that these quests are
never a distraction and always present a
good reward whether that be an item or
crafting materials at the very least
however most of the time they also
deliver some piece of law further flesh
out aside character or give Kratos a
trace and mimir something new to bond
over it is done if you could call so me
got a task done a wee draw part of the
Asgardian occupational bucket going
anywhere with these characters is an
exciting prospect and I often found
myself just wandering around to let
conversations play out or hoping that
new ones would start in most cases they
did and I was treated to another
valuable character growth moment in
Ragnarok Kratos is now more inquisitive
memir is always ready and willing to
offer his insight and atreus takes the
opportunity to make jokes at both their
expense and that's something I
definitely didn't expect God of War
Ragnarok is a funny game there are more
than a few laugh out loud moments that
endeared me to this new family unit that
developed over the last game and
flourishes in this one is everything
okay okay hi old friend just looting on
your chair we'll be right along my dad
likes Luke and that's what distinguishes
God of all Ragnarok from his predecessor
and most other action games despite
being a story about warring gods and the
end of the world the soul of the game is
something far more sentimental you may
have noticed that I've avoided
mentioning the names of characters or
describing plot beats and that was
intentional to talk more about anything
or anyone would be to rob you of some of
the most unexpected things that God of
War Ragnarok achieved so with this
narrative and the themes they explore
the last game's thoughtful approach to
exploring fatherhood was unexpected but
Ragnarok somehow manages to feel like an
even more personal tale about the
complicated nature of families and the
people that make them up for every
moment of brutality there's one of
genuine and relatable emotion how they
land will vary from person to person but
there are multiple that left me with
tears welling up if nothing else God of
War Ragnarok further cements Sony Santa
Monica's narrative team as one one of
the best in the business
[Music]
[Music]